there we go oh I feel it
[Music]
if you're a curry fanatic in New York
City you can map out the city based on
the best places to get your fix for
Jamaican and Flatbush Indian Pakistani
and curry Hill and in the East Village
for Japanese in and around Little Tokyo
Japanese curry rice doesn't get as much
shine in the US as ramen but it's
actually one of Japan's most popular
comfort foods to learn more about the
dish I'm headed to Suki a new curry rice
spot in the East Village to dive deep
into Japanese curry culture with my
friend Rina Sayama born in Japan and
raised in London Rina is a critically
acclaimed singer model and artist but
most importantly a curry head let's go
[Music]
so I'm here with my friend Rina and
we're gonna try some Japanese curry at
Sookie and I have to admit I've never
had Japanese curry before I can't
believe Oh can you give me kind of a
rundown a crash-course of what is
Japanese curry so Japanese curry is
something that people make a home it's
like a staple in the Japanese household
you typically make it with these instant
roof packets which all have like honey
and apples on the outside because it's
quite sweet it's as big as ramen but you
make at home
so you were born in Japan and then you
moved to the UK when you were 5 yes as
an immigrant how important is it for
food to be connected to your culture
immigrant families like might not show
love in the same way that like non
immigrant families do you know like we
don't get praised for stuff as much but
the food is always there the love is
always there through the food and my mom
used to pack like curry in these little
tiny Tupperware of boxes that you
just get really stained yellow and I'd
like as soon as I to open I know other
people would just be like what is that
but you know I like looking back now I'm
just like that that was just the best
thing ever that my mom could have done
for me yeah I mean yeah food is love all
right before we eat we're gonna toss it
to em you made in Japan for a little
crash course on Japanese curry hi des
lien it's any from any made in Japan
today I'm going to tell you a little bit
about cadet ice or Japanese curry so
cadet ice falls under the umbrella of yo
Shoku which in Japanese means kind of
western-style food it's believed that
curry was introduced to Japan via
anglo-indian naval officers that came to
Japan in the mid 1800s to the late 1800s
it's tailored of course to the Japanese
palate a little bit sweeter and a little
bit stewar and much sauce here but
absolutely delicious
almost every home cook has their version
of cadet ice and most people use this
this is Cod I drew and basically this is
curry Roux blocks that allow you to make
kadai ice super fast and easy sometimes
people have shredded fresh apples and
people like to add a little bit of honey
coconut milk even cheese so all those
little additions kind of customize your
cut ahead ice and this is what the
career looks like it's traditionally
served alongside some plain white rice
and the most basic and traditional form
contains pieces of chicken carrots
potatoes onions and this glorious
luscious khadiyah sauce alright ladies I
hope you found that useful see you next
time
so first up we have the classic chicken
katsu curry
Sookie uses dozens of spices in its
curry recipe including star anis
cardamom fenugreek and nutmeg the curry
is simmered for four hours and then left
to rest for days before serving it's
then paired with white rice and a panko
crusted chicken cutlet obviously the
chicken katsu is breaded so we want to
keep it as like dry and crispy as
possible so this is why it's been
separated so we just want to get it okay
and just pour on top ready on the rice
or on the chicken all right both yeah
you go first okay I'll follow oh yeah oh
my god okay okay here we go
that is like porn yay cut it I see this
I was saying about its spice sweet right
so the difference between this and like
the Indian curry is that I've had
it's definitely thicker got a gravy vibe
and sweeter yeah for sure mmm there's a
lot of like heavy spices that are very
savory with anyone but this one has like
a very soft way in my mouth I like
so can you tell me a little bit about
the katsu here I know that Japan is into
the fried chicken we have karaage then
we have the katsu what's the fascination
with fried chicken in Japan at Christmas
you eat KFC on Christmas Day like you
have to pre booked it months in advance
I don't know what it is I definitely
think it's an American influence in
Japan the food tends to be like the main
dish which is quite savory but then
you'd have the rice on the side to
balance it all out it's all about like
the depth of flavor rather than like it
hitting you right in the face
but this is amazing it's just like it
takes you on a little journey that's
sweet its savory its crispy I'm happy
next up we have Sookie's curry ramen the
curry sauce here is kicked up a notch
with a splash of dashi and a sprinkle of
kelp and then the bowl is topped with
pieces of shrimp I don't know if this is
true but I feel like a lot of Japanese
food especially it's like it's based on
what you can do with the leftovers or
has specific dish so maybe on Monday
you'll have curry and then you have a
little bit of leftover curry so then
you'll add the broth in and then make
curry udon or ramen okay there's a
phrase in Japanese there's called multi
night and it means like it's wasteful so
you try and use up everything you can
like and I feel like this is a perfect
example are you ready to slurp I'm ready
to slurp I love to flirt good the lucky
ones
[Music]
I'm also good is still what that
sweetness from the the khari rice that
we had our down the broth is amazing
use your dare get really like pissed off
when people change the original like are
you done
so usually it's with Bhutan is it
because it's a thicker noodle and then
it just sets with the curry better or I
remember when I was younger I was just
the little feature like documentary on
the science of curry udon
there is like a way that the curry like
wraps itself around the udon and so it's
like the best eating experience I don't
know actually I feel like the ramen that
captures so much broth I think it's like
actually a perfect vessel last but not
least we have yaki curry rice and dry
curry are baked in a casserole dish with
a thick layer of cheddar mozzarella and
Colby cheese melted on top you can't
even see the carian today there's so
much cheese this has truffle oil on top
oh my god right it's my favorite thing
ever is amazing let's go I've never
tried this before but I even know this
existed you break through something you
get like the hair savoury and then that
like that really intense amount of
truffle and then it's like again like
slightly sweet mm-hmm hurry that's mixed
in with the rice Oh
[Music]
so we've had a few dishes and I want to
know what are the common misconceptions
about Japanese food I would say that
it's expensive whenever I've had
Japanese food it's always cheap and you
can eat cheap and we can eat well so you
can eat on a budget but you really can't
stop going to Jiro that's not what
people eat go to convenience stores get
yourself on EGD get yourself little nuts
or my feet get yourself some allergy
there and just yeah you're so good for
the rest of the day what are some
misconceptions about being an Asian
woman like I feel like I've dealt with
so much [ __ ] with China proves that
I'm brown enough but I'm also just this
human there's a law I think the main one
for me is a Japanese woman is the kawaii
thing you know I think the word kawaii
has been totally like misappropriated
that's something I use for my job
you know I say my dog is kawaii or like
I studied look at like Hello Kitty and I
think that's Kali I think it really did
put Japanese women in a light that is
tokenizing sort of infantilizing and
objectifying so Thank You Reena for
joining me and eating with me you can
check out Riina's new single cherry on
all platforms and thank you Sufi for
letting us eat here and enjoying the
meals it was great well show someone I
stopped
[Music]